digamos que tenemos el polinomio de x y
cuando lo expresamos en su forma
factorizar es x + 2 que multiplica a 2 x
menos 3 que multiplica a x menos 4 y lo
que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es usar
nuestro conocimiento de las raíces de
este polinomio para pensar en los
intervalos donde este polinomio es
positivo o negativo la clave será que el
signo del polinomio es el mismo entre
dos ceros consecutivos déjame dibujar
una gráfica de un polinomio arbitrario
para que sea más claro lo que intento
decir tenemos el eje x el eje quien y si
dibujo un polinomio arbitrario como éste
puedes ver que entre 20 consecutivos el
signo es el mismo
entre este 0 y este otro 0 el polinomio
es positivo entre este 0 y este 0 el
polinomio es negativo y esto es casi
intuitivamente cierto porque si el signo
no fuera el mismo significa que tendrías
que cruzar el eje x y por lo tanto
tendrías un 0 esta es la razón del por
qué no cambia de signo entre dos ceros
consecutivos entonces entre este 0 y
este otro 0 la función que dibujamos es
de nuevo positiva y después de este 0 es
negativa una vez más la única forma de
que no sea negativa es si tuviéramos
otro cero pero regresemos a nuestro
ejemplo original para esto déjame borrar
lo que trazamos porque esta no es la
gráfica de px y primero pensemos en los
ceros
los 0 son los valores de x que resultan
de ya sea x + 2 igual a 0 o 2 x menos
tres igual a cero o x menos 4 igual a
cero así que primero pensemos en qué
valores de x resuelven x + 2 igual a 0
por supuesto es el valor de x igual a
menos 2 que el valor de x resuelve 2x
menos 3 igual a cero bueno si sumamos
tres de ambos lados obtengo 2x igual a 3
y si dividimos todo por 2 obtengo que x
es igual a tres medios y por último pero
no menos importante que el valor de x
resuelve x menos 4 igual a cero bueno
sumamos cuatro de ambos lados y
obtenemos x igual a 4
y si queremos graficar esto se parece a
algo así tengo x igual a menos 2 x
igualdad menos 10 1 2 3 4 y déjame
dibujar el eje en el eje se ve algo así
el eje x y el eje y tenemos un cero en x
igual a menos dos así que inter sacamos
al eje x aquí tenemos otro cero en tres
medios que es un entero con un medio que
está justo por aquí y además tenemos
otro cero en x igual a 4 es decir aquí
por lo tanto tenemos varios intervalos
candidatos así que déjame escribirlos en
una tabla los intervalos a considerar
son los intervalos entre los ceros
consecutivos déjame hacer una tabla
tenemos las x menores que menos 2
es el primer intervalo déjame ponerlo en
amarillo
tenemos el intervalo donde x está entre
menos dos y tres medios entonces menos 2
es menor que x menor que tres medios
este es el intervalo en rosa y bueno voy
a intentar usar todos mis colores
tenemos por acá otro intervalo donde x
está entre 3 medios y 4 es decir 3
medios es menor que x menor que 4 y por
último pero no por eso menos importante
el intervalo en rojo donde x es mayor
que 4x es mayor que 4
ahora hay un par de formas de pensar si
sobre este intervalo su función es
positiva o negativa uno de los métodos
es evaluar un punto del intervalo en
nuestra función pero si nos da un valor
positivo significa que todo el intervalo
es positivo y si es negativo significa
que todo el intervalo es negativo una
vez más es intuitivo porque si por
alguna razón cambiamos de signo entonces
tendríamos otro cero la otra forma es
pensar qué pasa en x + 2 en 2 x menos 3
y en x menos 4 en cada intervalo es
decir saber si estas expresiones son
negativas o positivas para después usar
nuestro conocimiento al multiplicar
signos positivos negativos para saber si
toda la función es positiva o negativa
así que hagámoslo de ambas formas
digamos que tenemos la muestra
x la muestra x nuestro valor de x que
representará al intervalo y por último
pensaremos si sobre este intervalo
tenemos un signo positivo o negativo
empecemos para las x menores que menos 2
podemos elegir como valor de muestra
cualquier valor menor que menos 20 x
igual a menos 3 es un valor sencillo
para evaluar podemos intentar evaluar
pd - 3 de hecho vamos a hacerlo pd - 3
es igual a menos tres más dos es lo
mismo que menos uno menos uno por 2 x
menos 3 que es igual a menos 6 menos 3
que es menos 9 menos 9 x menos 3 menos 4
lo cual es menos 7 y si multiplicas todo
esto obtendrás menos 63 que claramente
es negativo así que en este intervalo
nuestro polinomio será negativo así que
podemos movernos al siguiente intervalo
una cosa interesante es que no es
necesario resolver este valor de 63 lo
que en verdad nos interesa es el
lo que nos interesa es que tenemos un
negativo por un negativo por un negativo
que al final nos dará un valor negativo
así que hagamos de esta manera los
siguientes intervalos pensemos si cada
una de estas expresiones son positivas o
negativas y al final vamos a multiplicar
esos signos positivos y negativos en
este segundo intervalo entre menos 2 y 3
medios que pasaran bueno podemos
trabajar con un punto muestra el más
sencillo que se me ocurre es x igual a
cero cuando x es igual a cero estamos
trabajando con una primera expresión
positiva por una segunda expresión
negativa por una tercera expresión
negativa un positivo por un negativo por
un negativo la forma de resolverlo en mi
cabeza fue tengo dos positivos después
de esta segunda expresión me queda 3
negativo y en la última 4 negativo
entonces
positivo por un negativo por un negativo
déjame escribirlo un positivo por un
negativo por un negativo y bueno
negativo por negativo me dará positivo y
positivo por positivo es positivo así
que tenemos una función que es positiva
sobre este intervalo y si evaluamos p de
0 obtendrás un valor positivo ahora que
hay del siguiente intervalo donde tres
medios es menor que x menor que 4
podemos proponer a x igual a 2 cuando
evaluamos a x igualdad 2 obtenemos un
valor positivo en la primera expresión
por un valor positivo en la segunda
expresión por 2 menos 4 es negativo
así que por un valor negativo así que la
función tiene valores negativos sobre
este intervalo
y por último pero no menos importante
cuando x es mayor que 4 intentemos con x
igual a 5 cuando x es igual a 5 tenemos
primero un valor positivo por otro valor
positivo en la segunda expresión por un
valor positivo en la tercera así que en
este intervalo tenemos valores positivos
ahora bien como mencioné puedes obtener
las mismas conclusiones si los valores
de muestra puedes decir ok para
cualquier x mayor que 4 al sumarle 2 en
definitiva obtenemos un valor positivo
para cualquier x mayor que 4 al
multiplicarlo por 2 y al restarle 3 en
definitiva obtenemos algo positivo
porque 2 por algo más grande que 4 en
definitiva es algo más grande que 3 y
cualquier valor más grande que 4 al
restarle 4 obtienes siempre un valor
positivo así que esta es otra forma para
hallar el signo del intervalo incluso si
no tienes un valor muestra
y ya lo tenemos hallamos los intervalos
donde la función es positiva o negativa
aunque no sabemos exactamente cómo se ve
la función pero de manera general
podemos pensar que la función es
negativa en este primer intervalo es
decir se ve más o menos así después es
positiva en el siguiente intervalo
después es negativa en el tercer
intervalo y por último es positiva en el
último intervalo así que ya tenemos un
esbozo general de la función p no
sabemos exactamente qué tanto sube o
baja este polinomio hasta que probemos
con más puntos pero ya sabemos el signo
de cada uno de los intervalos